Міхаель Шудріх – головний равин Польщі
Уродженець Нью-Йорка вже тридцять років
мешкає у Варшаві
Він допомагав відроджувати єврейські громади після повалення комунізму
Насамперед у польській столиці
Цю синагогу спаплюжили німці в часи Голокосту
Після падіння "залізної завіси" її реконструювали
Громада пишається тим,
що у Польщі знову вирує єврейське життя
Але говорити про це на камеру ніхто не хоче
Через побоювання антисемітських нападів
Ми у новій ситуації. Ми чуємо речі,
яких не чули з 1968 року. Рівно 50 років
Що саме?
Вам не місце у Польщі. Їдьте до Ізраїлю
З'являються погані карикатури.
Поки, на щастя, без рукоприкладства
50 років тому таке вже було
Поляки, які пережили Голокост,
вимушено виїхали з країни
Студенти-учасники демонстрацій закидали польським євреям
що усі вони – опора репресивного
комуністичного режиму
Ліберально налаштований публіцист Костантій Ґеберт
один з небагатьох релігійних євреїв, які тоді залишилися у комуністичній Польщі
До нього приходить син.
Два покоління єврейського життя у Варшаві
Обоє теж закидають право-популістському урядові
що він недостатньо робить проти антисемітизму
Єврейський наступ на Польщу - такі карикатури  стали частіше з'являтися у провладних ЗМІ
Після цього треба помити руки
Чому це відбувається зараз?
Це відбувається через цей новий польський закон, який став каталізатором
Але, звичайно, антисемітизм завжди існував у сучасній Польщі
Він був і у комуністичні часи,
а після падіння режиму виринув знову
Згаданий Ґебертом закон про Голокост
вже набув чинності
і під загрозою тюремного ув'язнення забороняє
будь-які твердження про співучасть поляків у масовому знищенні євреїв
Публіцист написав колонку
в ліволіберальній "Газеті Виборчій"
Якщо суворо дотримуватись нового закону,
за цей текст його можуть засудити, каже Ґеберт
Я заявляю, що численні
представники польського народу
несуть співвідповідальність
за нацистські злочини, скоєні третім рейхом
За цей текст йому б загрожували
три роки ув'язнення
Уряд Ізраїлю вбачає у цьому обмеження
свободи слова і протестує
Дискусія отруїла побутові стосунки
між євреями та неєвреями у Польщі
Люди починають боятися
Мені лячно дискутувати у публічному просторі
казати, що я єврей, і взагалі вступати у дискусію
У нього кардинально протилежна думка
Артур Гофман очолює
Соціально-культурне товариство євреїв Польщі
створене після Другої світової
Це була найвагоміша
єврейська організація в часи комунізму
Гофман згадує у Варшавському університеті
про виїзд польських євреїв 50 років тому
під час тодішнього сплеску антисемітизму
Його спілка підтримує лінію
правопопулістського уряду
Гофман  хворобливо реагує на критику ззовні. Особливо з Німеччини
Поляків намагаються зробити співвідповідальними за "остаточне вирішення єврейського питання"
Якщо коротко: це ви зробили, а не ми, поляки.
Ви, німці, у цьому винні
Гофман показує нам рештки варшавського гетто
куди німці загнали понад
300 тисяч польських євреїв
У цій католицькій церкві, каже він,
працював священик-антисеміт
і все ж він допомагав євреям переховуватися
Антисемітська риторика у Польщі не має таких наслідків, як така ж риторика у Німеччині
Головний равин Міхаель Шудріх каже,
все не так просто
Він вимагає від польських політиків
гучного визнання
Антисемітизму в Польщі – не місце
Ми знаємо, що він може накоїти,
ми вже бачили це тут
Ми сьогодні у 2018-му, байдуже, праві, ліві чи центристи
не будемо терпіти антисемітизм
Лише так можна розвіяти страхи
у членів єврейської спільноти
Інакше, побоюється равин, нової хвилі
еміграції євреїв із Польщі не уникнути